algérie le gouvernement annonce
officiellement 103 morts dans un
massacre aux portes d'alger quinze jours
après le début du ramadan le bilan
s'établit mille victimes le mouvement
des chômeurs de nouvelle opération
spectaculaire en france à rendez-vous
sans résultat avec martine aubry
aujourd'hui est une journée nationale
d'action demain le péage des autoroutes
en ville remis en question par les
usagers à paris à lyon et surtout à
toulouse où les installations de péage
ont été démontées violence dans les
villes jacques chirac reçoit demain 12
maires notre enquête de ce soir montre
que malgré les divergences politiques il
ya un souci commun responsabilités liées
les eaux les parents des enfants
délinquants paris-dakar la plus belle
étape avec l'arrivée à ton doux tout 400
km de spéciale sur les bords du fleuve
niger dans un décor grandiose
madame monsieur bonsoir les mots comment
ça nous manquait véritablement pour
évoquer la situation en algérie
horreur massacre carnage quinze jours
après le début du ramadan le bilan est
d'environ 1000 morts le gouvernement
algérien jusqu'à présent le plus discret
possible sur cet engrenage de la terreur
annonce lui-même le bilan du dernier
massacre en date dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi 103 personnes exécutées
dans la localité de sidi ahmed à 25
kilomètres à peine du centre d'alger
malgré les risques et les difficultés
non reporter abderrahman bouzid y ont pu
se rendre sur place et enregistré là-bas
des témoignages terribles commentaire
jérôme body ont baptisée avenue
pour cette femme ont repris ce que se
demande s y survivre est une chance
jamais elles n'oublieront l'horreur de
la nuit dernière dont pourtant les
habitants essaient d'effacer le souvenir
peine perdue a sidi ahmed
on peut suivre le carnage à la trace les
maisons systématiquement visités par les
tueurs
ils étaient une centaine selon certains
témoignages appartenant sans doute au
gia les groupes islamiques armés
des familles entières brûlé tué à l'armé
blanche ou par balle et ils m'ont dit
mais toi je nous mets pas peur on est de
la police
mais moi je ne voulais pas mourir par le
couteau mon voisin naïf il s'est
agenouillé et ils l'on égorge wallonne
je ne voulais pas mourir par le couteau
préférait mourir par une balle alors il
a essayé de tirer mais la balle n'est
pas parti les autorités algériennes ont
donné le bilan du massacre d'hier soir
avec une rapidité inhabituelle 103 morts
ajoutant que ce bilan aurait pu être
encore plus lourd sans l'intervention
des brigades d'autodéfense cette tuerie
de cydia m'aide à quelque 25 kilomètres
d'alger démontre que les groupes
terroristes n'ont pas tous été chassés
vers l'ouest du pays
dans les grands hôpitaux d'alger les
familles attendent des nouvelles des
victimes dans la douleur et la colère
tout on a battu 4 au terrorisme
si les ont emmenés avec eux qui me l'a
dit on a fouillé la forêt ce matin il y
en avait 20 autour de la maison
je les ai vu de mes yeux ma dalton
les zorra nous mêmes par tous les moyens
avec jésus ou drones mais on ne veut pas
d'intervention étrangère ainsi dit ahmed
des groupes de femmes vont consoler
leurs voisins d'autres sont déjà prêts
pour l'exode
les morts sont mises en terre et la vie
du hamon ne sera plus jamais comme avant
pour la mare ce soir dans son émission
d'un monde à l'autre à 22h45 sur france
2 vous proposera une émission spéciale
algérie reportages témoignages donc sur
notre chaîne à partir de 22h45 en france
avant leur nouvelle journée d'action
nationale de demain les associations de
chômeurs ont encore organisées
aujourd'hui de nombreuses actions
spectaculaires occupation de mary ann
entamait ce dont ils ont qui l'ont
évacué ce soir en tout une vingtaine de
lieux publics et de locaux assedic sont
toujours occupées par des chômeurs en
banlieue parisienne à vitry-sur-seine
une soixantaine de chômeurs se sont
invités eux dans une grande surface pour
y pique [ __ ] à leur façon marc d'haene
à alban nicosie l'objectif est
symbolique
las au révélateur de bien des
frustrations environ 60 chômeurs de
longue durée ont envahi ce centre
commercial de la région parisienne comme
une forteresse dédié à la consommation
qui leur seraient inaccessibles
ça fait longtemps que vous n'aviez pas
manger de saumon fumé comme une demi
heure d'occupation pour un butin
dérisoire quelque part de galette des
rois une bouteille de mousseux et
surtout une visite systématique des
rayons pour tenter de rallier à leur
cause les clients ou moment des chômeurs
dits à l'ensemble de la société et ça ne
peut plus durer
nous sommes enfin de patience est
conscient que ce n'est pas les gaz qui
êtes en train de faire indique du vol
lundi légal de laisser crever les gens
alors c'est ça qui doit et qui doit être
rendue illégale
c'est des gens qui crèvent c'est des
gens qui n'ont pas d'avenir c'est les
gens qui sont en trop ça ça doit est il
légal
la manifestation s'est dispersée sans
incident en présence d'une vingtaine de
crs chargés d'empêcher tout vol massif
cette association chômeurs qui milite
pour une réforme complète du système
d'assurance chômage a annoncé sa
participation aux actions envisagées
demain dans la capitale à cherbourg dans
la manche une partie de la population
s'est jointe aux chômeurs alors que se
tenait une réunion à la sous préfecture
en présence de tous les acteurs de la
vie économique locale et se soit bien
les chômeurs occupent à nouveau le
centre d'action sociale de la ville
reportage damien thévenot rémy poinçonné
leur en a 19 ans il n'a jamais trouvé de
travail jusqu'au mois dernier
il vivait avec pour seul revenu 2000
francs par mois versé par la dass
aujourd'hui il ne perçoit plus un
centime
cette pluie comme les jours précédents
il ne dormira pas dans son studio il
posera son paquetage dans le centre
d'action sociale investi en fin d'après
midi par ses amis chômeurs je reste
enfermée chez moi avant la fin j'en ai
tellement marre je me suis pour ça que
je suis là aujourd'hui pour revendiquer
tout ce qui se passe marçais jusque là
ce matin
il espérait vraiment que la table ronde
entre élus représentants des assedic
aurait abouti
un millier de chômeurs lycéens et
salariés de l'arsenal main dans la main
devant la sous préfecture
le ras-le-bol d'une ville fortement
touché par le chômage 15 % de la
population sur cherbourg en les mères de
famille on a des enfants s'inquiète pour
l'avenir du bon vin par solidarité on
est là j'ai loupé une aire d'espagne
aller une heure d'histoire
j'y passais mes profs sont contents mais
c'est pour notre site sur je pense que
retire la connaître chômage ok un
roulement de personnel municipal et les
accompagnants si les chômeurs ont obtenu
ce soir quelques avancées comme la
gratuité des transports pour les
familles les plus modestes
tout est loin d'être réglé ils réclament
toujours un relèvement de 1500 francs
des minima sociaux et le rmi pour les
moins de 25 ans à cherbourg cette nuit
ils seront une cinquantaine à dormir sur
un matelas de fortune
la municipalité a promis de ne pas les
déloger à paris le ministre de l'emploi
et de la solidarité martine aubry a reçu
une nouvelle fois les associations de
chômeurs et les représentants de la cgt
à leur sortie ils ont indiqué que leurs
actions continuaient dans la mesure où
il n'avait obtenu aucune réponse sur les
points essentiels de leurs
revendications laurent bailly et filip
chasselas les représentants des chômeurs
commence à bien connaître le chemin des
ministères aujourd'hui leur
interlocuteur n'était pas lionel jospin
mais la ministre de l'emploi martine
aubry au menu mes futures mesures contre
le chômage et l'exclusion en sortant de
la réunion
les associations se félicite de la
rapidité du déblocage du milliard de
francs d'urgence promis jeudi dernier
cette somme attribuée par les préfets
sera disponible dès demain est
absolument essentiel pour nous du
relèvement des minimas sociaux et du
droit à un revenu pour les jeunes qui
sont deux mesures je répète
incontournable pour lutter contre
l'exclusion
il n'y a ce soir aucune réponse positive
conséquence la mobilisation continue les
chômeurs veulent même l'élargir aux
salariés les salariés qui distille
aurait tout à gagner d'une hausse
sensible des minima sociaux ça empêchera
les patrons qui embauchent à moins de
4000 francs par mois dans les
supermarchés ailleurs d'être obligé de
relever les salaires et ça c'est un bon
moyen parce qu'on sait bien que la
précarité ça tire vers le bas les
salaires
des manifestations sont prévues demain
dans les grandes villes
ce soir les chômeurs préparent leurs
slogans hostiles au patronat le
gouvernement n'est plus la cible
exclusive ni prioritaire sur le terrain
les discours de ces dernières semaines
commencent à porter leurs fruits
notamment les cellules d'urgence qui à
partir des préfectures accélère les
procédures dead qui sont déjà en place
il faut signaler éric perrin frédéric
van hecke abonde premier objectif et
premier problème des cellules d'urgence
identifier les cas nécessitant une
action rapide commune de mérignac à côté
de bordeaux 60 mille habitants 12 % de
chômage
ici comme ailleurs le ccas centre
communal d'action sociale est au coeur
des problèmes de solidarité
c'est donc dans ses locaux situés dans
l'amérique que les formulaires sont
mises à disposition en deux jours cinq
personnes sont venues les remplir
sur ces cinq personnes il se trouve qu
effectivement que quatre personnes
n'avaient pas l'habitude de faire appel
aux services sociaux comme par exemple
un célibataire avec 2200 francs mensuels
d'allocations chômage et près de 7000
francs de dettes loyer factures impayées
un cas jusqu'à l'heure inconnues à la
place des gens c'est pas évident de
franchir la porte d'un service social et
de dire mais j'ai quand même taille et
vous voyez comme les factures
tous les jours les centres sociaux vont
désormais envoyée par fax et formulaire
à la préfecture de région
c'est elle qui anime cette cellule
d'urgence où tous les organismes sociaux
sont représentés mais également
d'éventuels créanciers comme france
télécom edf ou encore l'inspection
d'académie pour des factures de cantine
à payer les cellules d'urgence vont être
pérennisé sous forme de missions
d'urgence et leur rôle ainsi que les
moyens dont elles disposeront vont
évoluer dans les jours qui viennent
car pour le moment cette cellule ne
dispose d'aucun fonds particulier
supplémentaires et pour les chômeurs qui
continuent leur action
le terme urgence peut prêter à confusion
beaucoup de gens apprenant qu'eric
cellule de crise on tente dans sa fille
marine et qu'il suffit de remplir les
formulaires pour immédiatement de
recevoir l'argent en se présentant au
guichet de la préfecture qui fait regret
un petit peu de l'organisme payeur c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça se passe et
je pense que la vérité doit être
rétablie c'est plutôt des cellules
d'accélération que les cellules
d'urgence jugé malgré tout comme une
avancée par les chômeurs ces cellules
d'urgence doivent maintenant faire
preuve de leur efficacité encore de
réaction politique le mouvement des
chômeurs a été au centre des débats du
parti communiste aujourd'hui le pc
demande de au gouvernement de faire plus
et condamne les évacuations par les
forces de l'ordre mary je pense qu'ils
vont viens danser dans ces situations de
dialoguer plutôt convoyer les forces de
l'ordre c'est évident on est absolument
je crois que il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté de
la part des communistes sur cette
question vous avez les communistes sont
partie prenante de de ce mouvement ils
ont ils vont apporter son soutien dès le
départ nous sommes au coeur de ce
mouvement
modifions pas notre point de vue en la
matière et puis à l'occasion de ses
voeux à la presse jean-pierre
chevènement le ministre de l'intérieur
s'est visiblement montré ce soir agacé
par le mouvement des chômeurs il estime
que les forces de l'ordre ont autre
chose à faire que d'évacuer les lieux
publics occupés monsieur chevènement
mais c'est certainement mieux à faire
que de tirer par les pieds des
spécialistes les sit in à je pense que
on la demande dans les quartiers chauds
à l'âge où de jeunes sauvageons brûle à
la voiture de leurs voisins ou bien
encore on aimerait voir les crs sur les
pistes des ski où il assure aussi la
sécurité des gens pour la police elle a
beaucoup de choses à faire à moi me le
demande partout tout le monde me demande
des renforts
voyons la république devant la presse
aujourd'hui pour ses voeux après les
critiques contre le gouvernement jospin
de ces derniers jours une phrase plutôt
positives à propos de la cohabitation
qu'il souhaite at il dit constructive la
violence dans les villes sera demain au
centre d'une réunion à l'élysée
justement entre le président de la
république et douze maires de villes
françaises beaucoup d'expérience sont
menées pour tenter de maîtriser le
phénomène de la violence mais on a
parfois l'impression que tout reste à
faire à commencer par l'éducation des
plus petits face à la police reportage
édifiant dans le département de
l'essonne olivier galzi patrick des
speakers au coeur de la cité un cours
particulier les enfants juges les
policiers représente pour vous la police
pour cet enfant tout de suite sa
première représentation du mal parce
qu'il tue les gens ils ne sont pour rien
ils jettent des cocktail molotov et des
bombes lacrymogènes
et ça ce n'est pas bien casser les
représentations mettre un visage
derrière un uniforme la police retourne
à l'école pour expliquer et s'expliquer
voulait grandir vous avez l'envié vous
allez faire du quartier ce que vous
pensez de ce quartier donc je pense que
chacun d'entre vous vous soumettez qui
change ce quartier oui
alors qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
vous allez arrêter de taper mes
policiers est ce que vous prenez en
lisant ce genre de texte une grande
détresse pour certains pour d'autres
beaucoup d'attentes
cette fonction détection curieux à
l'extrême les enfants s'attachent aussi
le détail
et quand l'inspecteur sur sa carte de
police c'est l'émeute dans la cour à cet
instant le regard des enfants change la
fonction s'efface derrière un homme
visiblement ravi par cette expérience
moi je crois que c'est ça va bien cette
année 22 rencontres de ce genre auront
lieu toujours dans des quartiers
sensibles
un moyen peut-être de rendre à la police
son vrai visage celui de la proximité et
dans ce contexte de violence les
syndicats de police sont très sensibles
à tout ce qui touche à leur image de
marque dans le public
ainsi le syndicat général de la police
vient de demander le retrait d'un jeu
vidéo qui vous propose d'être tout
simplement l'ennemi numéro 1 en battant
au passage passants et policiers tirer
curtet françois gagne le but du jeu
devenir le caïd l'ennemi public numéro
un
et pour cela tous les coups sont permis
meurtres de policiers trafic de drogue
ou cambriolage seul compte l'objectif si
la violence dans les jeux vidéo est
relativement courante
il est très rare que le scénario propose
aux joueurs d'endosser les habits du
méchant de l'immoral des polices
et puis et puis il faut donner des aussi
des coups de poing aux gens qui passent
la violence est ici beaucoup plus
supposer que visuel mais le jeu choc les
syndicats de policiers en priorité c'est
le scénario proposé parce qu'on sait que
la violence existe elle est latente dans
l'environnement de l'enfant
beaucoup de partenaires sociaux en
débattent actuellement d'ailleurs et là
le scénario est particulier et il fait
appel à tout ce qui est mauvais chez
l'homme et chez l'enfant général du côté
de l'importateur on affirme s'être posé
beaucoup de questions avant de mettre ce
jeu sur le marché un avertissement en
anglais puis un autocollant
déconseillant la vente aux moins de 16
ans fait office de prévention on se
défend d'avoir voulu un scénario
uniquement basée sur la violence et
l'immoralité essentiel des jeunes at
n'allait pas dans ce qu'attend le
consommateur in fine est au fond lui le
au fond de lui dans la vie de l'école
qu'il a connu quand dans les petites
classes il avait autant de fois envie
d'être le gendarme qui dope le voleur le
syndicat de policiers a saisi le
ministère de l'intérieur l'importateur
du jeu se dit lui prêt à rendre son
avertissement déconseillé au moins de
saison plus visible environ douze maires
de grandes villes françaises qui seront
reçus demain par le chef de l'état ils
sont de sensibilité politique très
différente leur solution face à la
violence ne sont pas forcément les mêmes
mais pour deux d'entre eux le maire de
rosny-sous-bois udf en banlieue
parisienne et le maire de mulhouse
socialiste un point commun au moins la
responsabilisation des parents en quête
france de quilles à patrik sandell
responsabiliser les parents
rationaliser on le veut tous bien sûr
mais les moyens et bien est-ce que c'est
l'incantation est ce que c'est la
punition la sanction effectivement en
nous immergeant un exemple
les allocations familiales le maire de
rosny-sous-bois n'exclut pas leur
suppression
celui de mulhouse propose des solutions
moins radicales
moi je pense notamment à la mise sous
tutelle des allocations familiales dans
certains cas qui sont d'ailleurs prévues
par la loi française
je pense à des mesures de couvre-feu
individuelles concernant certains
mineurs qui seraient je dirais confié à
leurs parents avec interdiction de
laisser sortir
bockel pernès une préoccupation la ville
tous deux se rendent à l'elysée demain à
l'invite de jacques chirac cela tombe
bien ils ont deux mots à dire au
président monsieur le président voilà
des années que plusieurs ministres se
penche sur le sort des banlieues et
mettent en place des politiques les
empile les unes aux autres
voilà un art gens formidables qui est
dispensé vers les communes et ça ne
marche pas ça ne marche pas parce que
c'est trop compliqué compliquer la mise
en place de ce chantier école pourtant
l'opération fonctionne ici une poignée
de personnes réhabilite l'ancienne
mairie de rosny sous bois
hier en voie d'exclusion les voilà
aujourd'hui sur les rails de l'insertion
que je vais dire au président sait que
s'il n'ya pas l'espoir d'avoir une
feuille de paye permettant de faire des
emprunts de se marier de se loger et
bien vous avez des pierres sur l'autobus
à mulhouse jean marie bockel ne fait pas
autre chose avec cette entreprise
d'insertion spécialisée dans leur
passage huit emplois à la clé c'est peu
et beaucoup à la fois
bon pour le monde quoi pour vous enfants
ça leur apporte quoi ben c'est pas ça
leur fait du bien de voir et savoir que
l'armement travail tout le travail
bonjour mesdames bonjour les enfants
tout le travail que nous avons que nous
faisons avec les habitants et leurs
représentants sur le plan social sur le
plan de l'emploi sur le plan de la
prévention
aujourd'hui atteint sa limite car jean
marie bockel estime avoir fait le
maximum pour améliorer le cadre de vie
ici quelques 300 logements ont été
réhabilités et à rosny sous bois
on a réfléchi avant de construire autour
d'un practice de golf on organise le
mélange des populations ou par exemple
de mixité sociale
regardez vous avez d'un côté les hlm
ensuite vous avez les logements à loyers
libres en location vous avez les
logements en accession à la propriété
vous avez ici un golf et tout en bas les
emplois c'est un exemple donc complet où
tout le monde cohabite et jusqu'à là et
bien pas de problème les élus à vous la
fragilité de leurs solutions voilà
pourquoi chacun croit tant ce rendez
vous élyséen
en espérant ne pas être dupes et moi
j'attends que le président de la
république
il nous aide à sortir ces questions de
délinquance juvénile lyon urbaine et
surtout de délinquance juvénile du champ
de la polémique la confrontation voire
de la démagogie c'est bien que la
démagogie elle favorise toujours les
favoris pour les extrêmes
bref à deux mois des élections
régionales les élus de base demande aux
poids lourds de la politique de faire
preuve
comment dire de civisme un chiffre un
patient zéro en france en décembre selon
l'insee sur les douze derniers mois une
progression de 1,1 pour cent contre 27,7
et en 1996 et nouvelle conséquence de la
chute des bourses en asie
une baisse de près de 2% de la bourse de
paris cet après-midi le péage sur les
autoroutes en ville remis en question
par plusieurs associations aujourd'hui
des manifestations ont eu lieu à lyon
vous les voyez sur ces images paris et
surtout à toulouse où un péage urbain a
déjà été supprimée mais le prix de cette
suppression devra être supporté par les
contribuables
reportage et christophe la banque le ph
de roques sur garonne on la construit en
en 1998 on le détruit c'est le premier
péage en france à être ainsi démantelé
sous la pression des usagers cette
guerre du paiement les autoroutes du sud
de la france quand payer très cher
aujourd'hui elle pète encore pour le
démonter c'est quand même un sacré
gaspillage non je voulais pas dire c'est
avec talent au gaspillage dépensé 10
millions de francs aujourd'hui pour
casser ce qui a coûté 180 millions je
pense pas que ce soit une bonne affaire
sur le plan de la bonne utilisation
roques sur garonne c'était le prototype
même du péage urbain faire payer à
l'automobiliste 5 francs pour un
kilomètre d'une quatre voies déjà
existantes et gratuite
transformée en autoroute mais les
usagers en réagi dénonçant un racket
sous leur pression les collectivités
territoriales ont dû racheter le péage
aux asf 180 millions de francs ces chers
trois fois plus que si le tronçon
n'avait jamais été concédée à une
société autoroutière
effectivement ça me fait de rappel sur
les 180 millions de francs mais je
préfère ça à 30 ans de concession
c'est un gaspillage mais j'espère que
tout le monde s'en rappellera et puis
que quelque part les usagers les
citoyens existe qui peuvent se réveiller
un moment donné et d'y rêver de ça on
n'en veut pas que les questions de
principe on ira au bout et ça il faut
surtout en tirer les enseignements et
sarah polley 40,91 les asf avait déjà
proposé aux collectivités de racheter le
péage
le prix 67 millions de francs mais
conseil régional conseil général ville
de toulouse et petites communes
desservies poussé par des antagonismes
politiques n'avaient pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord
sous la pression de la rue les mêmes
interlocuteurs vont payer trois fois
plus cher mais aujourd'hui la leçon il
passait une bonne négociation vaut mieux
que comme banques andrew comme ovi com
baggies même entre adversaires
politiques
tafer ou so lu ment et la victoire de
rock n'a pas démobilisé les opposants au
péage urbain ce soir à toulouse ils
étaient plusieurs dizaines à manifester
pour leur suppression
partout en france c'est la fin
officielle du monopole des pompes
funèbres qui était déjà largement battu
en brèche il faut le dire désormais plus
de passage obligé la concurrence va
pourra jouer à plein ce qui ne signifie
pas par forcément pardon une baisse des
tarifs reportage à corbeil-essonnes en
région parisienne elizabeth est gelée
elle dit en choeur à corbeil-essonnes
on compte environ 600 enterrement par an
jusqu'à présent la mairie on assurait la
moitié les pompes funèbres générales
seul entreprises privées de la ville se
partageaient les autres avec quelques
concurrents de la région depuis
l'ouverture à la concurrence
la mairie a vu fermer boutique sans
regret le secteur funéraire était
déficitaire pour elle et elle n'a pas
d'inquiétude pour ses clients le fait
d'ouvrir le marché sur l'ensemble des
entreprises privées va créer une
émulation une véritable concurrence qui
n'existait pas jusqu'à maintenant et je
ne pense pas que les particuliers en
soient victimes peut-être même au
contraire un meilleur service au
meilleur prix ici la fin des
enterrements municipaux étaient très
attendus le marbrier à côté du cimetière
vient de se reconvertir dans les pompes
funèbres et une toute nouvelle boutique
est en cours d'installation
juste en face des pfg la concurrence va
être rude mais les prix ne vont pas
forcément plongez donc privé les tarifs
vont baisser par rapport à la con
curan si vous voulez parce que nous
sommes des entreprises privées mais les
tarifs ne vont pas baisser par rapport
aux tarifs des pamphlets municipal pas
du tout même pas du tout en passant par
la mairie 7 et 30 % moins cher
cette différence était parfois mal
ressentie par les entreprises la
situation leur paraît plus clair
aujourd'hui nous allons maintenant le
retrouver dans un combat à armes égales
avec des entreprises qui seront dans le
même cycle dans la même situation que
nous obligées de répercuter la tva
donc nous ne pouvons que nous satisfaire
de ce nouvel état des choses une
satisfaction dans la ville à l'origine
du mot corbillard il vient du nom
débarque qui au xvème siècle
transportait les corps des pestiférés de
paris à corbeil réunion des pays du
conseil de l'europe à paris pour décider
d'une interdiction officielle des
dérives du clonage de l'animal à l'homme
pour le président jacques chirac seule
une prise de position au niveau
international peut empêcher cette dérive
inquiétante
jean daniel flaysakier par la signature
d'elisabeth guigou
la france a confirmé ce soir qu'elles
sont posées au clonage d'êtres humains
comme un certain nombre de pays membres
du conseil de l'europe réunie
aujourd'hui à paris
19 pays ont en effet décidé qu'on ne
pouvait pas faire n'importe quoi avec
l'espèce humaine
ces pays signataires ils sont 19 ont
décidé de se prononcer pour
l'interdiction de créer génétiquement un
être humain vivant semblable à un autre
être que celui ci soit vivant ou mort
ils ont même prévu des sanctions pénales
et des interdictions d'exercice enfin
pour ceux qui voudraient rejoindre le
personnage comme le dr si la chicago qui
veut clooney des êtres humains
d'autres volets pénaux sont déjà prévus
on ne résoudra rien qu'on interdisant
certaines pratiques dans un pays si les
chercheurs et les médecins peuvent les
développeurs ailleurs c'est bien au
niveau international qu'il faut''
interdire le clonage et les
manipulations génétiques susceptibles
d'altérer les caractères de l'espèce
humaine
mais la grande bretagne où les dolly com
d'autres pays n'ont toujours pas signé
il y aura toujours un laboratoire
capable d'offrir à une personne sa copie
conforme
et ce malgré tous les traités du monde
un nouveau cas de vache folle détecté
dans la manche ce qui porte à 32 le
nombre de cas répertoriés en france
depuis 1990 demain la commission de
bruxelles devrait adopter une directive
visant à lever partiellement l'embargo
contre le boeuf britannique la vente
d'animaux venu d'irlande du nord serait
à nouveau autorisé le froid et surtout
le verglas continuent de sévir sur le
nord des états unis et principalement le
canada l'armée canadienne a été appelé
en renfort pour rétablir l'électricité
la circulation routière quant au
canadien
eh bien ils font preuve d'une solidarité
remarquer pour héberger ceux qui n'ont
plus de chauffage reportage philippe
gassot l'armée descendus dans la rue et
dans les parcs sinistrés de montréal
depuis le début de la tempête il s'agit
de retirer toutes les branches cassées
et surtout celles qui pourraient gêner
le rétablissement du courant
il s'agit pour les soldats de sécuriser
la population qui devra elle le sait
maintenant s'armer de patience il
apporte des générateurs visite les
abords des domiciles isoler enfin
sécurisé pour les habitants de montréal
les militaires dans la rue c'est
l'exception
les employés d'hydro-québec l'edf
québécois n'arrête pas leur travail
s'est fréquemment 12 à 15 heures par
jour et ce depuis le début de la tempête
il y a tout juste une semaine
pascal qu'est-ce qui est celle là c'est
la température les branches la glace
c'est de rétablir aussi deux chorales
plus tôt possible
par mike tyson dans la nuit plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de familles ont été
raccordés au réseau le travail de fourmi
devra se poursuivre encore longtemps la
population comprend sans montrer trop
d'énervement pour le moment pour ceux
qui ne veulent pas abandonner leurs
maisons
il y a le bois donner gratuitement et
souvent apporté comme ici par des
bénévoles qui offrent leur propre
production à la communauté en difficulté
ceux qui ont trop froid se dirige vers
les refuges dans celui ci concert 1500
repas parcours
le personnel est épuisé
commettant quatre jours
ra
les véritables héros pour la population
ce sont les pompiers
ceux qui n'ont conseil ni leur peine ni
leur temps à eux aussi sont là pour
assurer la sécurité en retirant par
exemple les 15 à 20 centimètres de glace
où le vent a plaqué sur les immeubles à
montréal et dans la région on est obligé
de s'apercevoir que les politiques
avaient largement mésestimer les délais
nécessaires aux réparations
depuis la nuit dernière deux cent mille
foyers nouveaux ont été raccordés au
réseau
mais les refuges ne désemplissent pas
c'est pas une première mais à ce point
c'est un phénomène de même assez rare il
a beaucoup neigé sur tel-aviv et
jérusalem au point que l'autoroute qui
relie les deux villes israéliennes a dû
être fermée jérusalem charles enderlin
victimes de la tempête benyamin
netanyahou le premier ministre n'a pas
pu regagner le domicile conjugal hier
soir il a dû rester à telle allure
en effet la route de jérusalem n'a
dégagé que ce matin il a fallu
l'intervention de transport de troupes
de l'armée pour ouvrir certains axes de
circulation et quelques chasses neige de
la municipalité étant insuffisant dix
centimètres de neige pour les
hiérosolymitains c'est trop beaucoup
trop
et toutes les écoles ainsi que de
nombreuses administrations sont restés
fermés
la journée était chômée l'occasion de
découvrir une jérusalem insolite dont
les lieux saints sont habillés de blanc
devant le mur des lamentations quelques
fidèles n'ont pas résisté leur bonhomme
de neige est tout-à-fait orthodoxe à
l'autre bout de la ville les habitants
du zoo biblique n'apprécie visiblement
pas les caprices de la météo israélienne
on le signale aucun incident israéliens
et palestiniens était pour une fois
occupé à d'inoffensives bataille il
faudrait peut-être qu'il neige plus
souvent à jérusalem
quand tu encore au rwanda 9 religieuses
ont été massacrés par des rebelles hutus
au rwanda donc dans l'attaqué d'un
couvent la frontière avec l'ex zaïre on
n'a pas plus d'informations pour le
moment en france demain s'ouvre un
procès en marge de la sphère du meurtre
du pasteur doucé souvenez-vous assassiné
en 1990 sans que le ou les coupables
étaient retrouvés à ce jour ce procès
c'est celui des méthodes des services de
renseignements généraux qui de longs
mois avant la mort du pasteur avait
littéralement mise en fiche ses moindres
faits et gestes
reportage eric lemasson 19 juillet 1990
un pasteur protestant défenseur des
minorités sexuelles est enlevé à son
domicile
la sphère du pasteur doucé éclate on
découvre alors que les renseignements
généraux suivait ses moindres faits et
gestes
nous avons eu accès à ces documents de
l'époque les voici
photo du pasteur prises par les rg
document qui montre aussi que les
policiers notent entrées/sorties
identité des visiteurs au 3 bis rue
claireaux paris 17ème nouvelle série de
photos le 3 juin
le pasteur organise une réunion débat
sur la pédophilie nouvelle surveillance
le 12 juillet la ligne téléphonique de
joseph doucet sera mis sur écoute jour
et nuit
trois mois plus tard un cadavre sera
découvert par un promeneur en forêt de
rambouillet joseph doucé enlevé
assassiné pourquoi par qui quel fut le
rôle de certains arg 7 ans ont passé
la vérité ne sort pas 13h30 demain 17e
chambre correctionnelle de paris
deux parmi les plus hauts responsables
de la police parisienne de l'époque sa
saison sur le banc des prévenus une
première judiciaire
pierre vers bruges était préfet de
police claude bardon directeur des rg
parisien ils ont ordonné des écoutes sur
la ligne du pasteur doucé écoutent oui
ou non il légal diront les juges dans ce
dossier annexe à la faire la justice se
penche sur les méthodes des
renseignements généraux
ce sont des écoutes étaient pratiquées
sans qu'il y ait une voie spécifique
concernant mais de telles écoutes
étaient tout à fait réglementaire
c'est à dire qu'elle s'était faite avec
l'autorisation de toutes les plus hautes
autorités de l'état et l'anah toujours
aux états un troisième policier l'
inspecteur des rg jean marc dufour est
l'homme clé de la faire douce et depuis
il a été révoqué de la police lui sera
jugé demain pour avoir rédigé de faux
rapports faux rapports que voici 19
juillet jour de la disparition du
pasteur
l'inspecteur du fourbe cacher sa
présence sur les lieux à l'heure de
l'enlèvement
ils trichent sur les horaires les faux
rapports qui ont été établies par
monsieur dufour montre qu'il a
constamment que constamment on a cherché
à s'éloigner de la disparition de la
mort de douces et alors que les
renseignements généraux étaient
constamment présent est tellement
présent qu'ils écoutent et même les
lignes téléphoniques
c'est dire qu'il savait tout ce qui se
passait et qu'ils étaient là quelques
minutes avant qu'il ne disparaisse
joseph doucé est il mort à la suite
d'une bavure ou de tout autre chose
avait il connaissance de secret
compromettants ces questions ne seront
pas examinés seuls les écoutes
téléphoniques les faux rapports et les
méthodes des rg sont l'objet du procès
la disparition du pasteur sera dans tous
les esprits dans les esprits seulement
le dossier lui est à l'instruction
depuis sept ans et pour longtemps encore
probablement
à noter encore que l'homme qui avait
tenté d'escroquer de l'argent aux
parents de la petite marion qui a été
enlevée il y à un peu plus d'un an
agents agen pardon leur promettant de la
retrouver a été mise en examen
aujourd'hui et il a été incarcéré le
sport 7 est aujourd'hui la plus belle
étape du rallye paris dakar qui après
une journée de repos emmenait les
concurrents de gao tombouctou 400 km de
spéciale sur les bords du fleuve niger
dans un paysage grandiose françois
brabant à pierre le p tit
c'est pas parce que c'est plus tout à
fait le désert que c'est forcément un
long fleuve tranquille
le dakar et sur les rives du niger
l'étape traditionnellement la poubelle
du rhin avec du sable et avec de l'eau
on est à peu près sûr que ces grands
gamins de concurrents vont avoir de quoi
s'amuser
sauf que le dakar s'est jamais un jeu
d'enfant
y'a un petit qu'il ya un petit bien les
pièges du sida aujourd'hui tout le monde
a une envie de pousser sa chanson pour
sauter ou l'espagnol s'est un peu rock'n
roll pour l'équipage resoudde ou talent
ça ressemble plutôt à une balade ils
n'arrêtent pas encore trois ans pour
david castera c'est le blues et des
bleus partout normal je sommet plus j'ai
mal partout
ils ont étendu les pouvoirs repartir on
va tout et porte même si avec vraiment
trop ferrer je me produis aussi et pour
mes unis l'italien s'est pas sur mon nom
c'est la chanson de gs geste
d'énervement de grosses colères même
après sans gps et boussole électronique
tombé en panne en plein désert
curieux mais dans ces moments là même
ceux qui ne maîtrisent pas forcément la
langue n'ont pas besoin de traduction
côté moto sotelo en rouge a gagné
l'étape mais peterhansel en bleu est
toujours leader au général
côté voitures saab y est arrivé avant
fontenay mais fontenay général reste
devant sa guise bref ces quatre là la
chanson du dakar ils la connaissent par
coeur
au menu maintenant musique classique
c'est ce que vous découvrirez si vous
passez un jour par lyon dans un petit
bistrot entre un bon plat de charcuterie
bien vous pourrez écouter un concert de
musique classique donc la bonne cuisine
la musique deux formes de cultures qui
cohabitent parfaitement didier guyot et
thiery simonet
le lieu du cancer est insolite et
pourtant c'est bel et bien le mariage
d'un bistrot de la musique classique au
menu beethoven chostakovitch mais aussi
charcuterie lyonnaise saint marcellin et
saint joseph dont sera l'oreille
plaisirs de la bouche c'est la scène du
routier l'homme où on peut le cuisiner
puis cuisinier pardon est un petit peu
cultivé on n'est pas
on y voit des gueux quoi moi j'ai une
culture dont la cuisine mais bon j'aime
c'est d'autres d'autres passions
faire son retour la musique classique de
son ghetto et dans le même temps faire
découvrir à certains des accents d'un
quatuor c'est l'ambition d'un modeste
restaurateurs qui aime tellement la
musique qu'il veut la partager avec les
autres
on n'a pas les conditions sans tacite
d'un concert mais le problème le contact
humain
vous avez vu ce soir que les musiciens
sont mélangés je veux dire au public et
ils mangent ensemble d'exonérations et
discutent ensemble
si bien
sympa
j'aime bien tibétain pour mettre en
bouche ensuite une petite salade
charcuterie à saint-marceau l'homme
voilà tout va bien
on
quoique les musiciens maintenant vont
vers le public et des rencontres comme
ça et c'est une demande des deux des
artistes aussi ce que nous aussi on aime
aussi partager ce qu'on aime notre
convivialité dans notre bonheur et je
crois que ces messages de l'amérique
ce soir là le quatuor cheli niasse et
désigne une nouvelle féret il en va
ainsi chaque troisième jeudi du mois
la nouvelle est tombée juste avant ce
journal un avion militaire s'est écrasé
près de l'aéroport de nîmes il est tombé
sur un terre-plein près d'une route le
pilote de l'avion était tuée il ya un
tue également parmi les passagers d'une
voiture les premières images parce
qu'elle douce est bon oui cet avion est
analysé un monomoteur qui appartient à
l'aéronavale
trois personnes étaient à son bord il
s'est écrasé juste à côté de l'aéroport
à côté de la route qui longe les pistes
l'un des occupants a été retirée morts
des décombres
les deux autres passagers sont blessés
blessé également les deux personnes qui
se trouvaient dans cette voiture qui
apparemment s'est retournée en essayant
d'éviter l'appareil les pompiers sont
toujours à l'oeuvre à cette heure si on
ne dispose pas d'autres précisions pour
l'instant
le rappelle maintenant des autres grands
titres de l'actualité d'abord l'algérie
le gouvernement allonge officiellement
103 morts dans un massacre aux portes
d'alger quinze jours après le début du
ramadan le bilan s'établit à 1000
victimes spécial algérie ce soir d'un
monde à l'autre sur france 2 le
mouvement des chômeurs de nouvelle
opération spectaculaire en france un
rendez vous sans résultat avec martine
aubry et une journée nationale d'action
prévue pour demain matin dans quelques
instants la météo sophie davant avec un
avis de tempête pour demain sur la
façade atlantique de nouveau la bretagne
avec des rafales de vent jusqu'à 130
kilomètres/heure 20h50 entre terre et
mer
la grande saga de lundi soir sur france
2 demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra alain et or
maire ps parti socialiste des mureaux
près de paris
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur le prochaine bonsoir allemand